un trafic exceptionnel ce dimanche 31
janvier avec presque 400 kilomètres de
bouchons relevé dans l'heure précédant
le début du couvre-feu au péage de
buchelay sur l'a13 le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a assisté au
contrôle des forces de l'ordre pour le
respect du couvre-feu à 18 heures il a
annoncé que ces derniers allaient être
intensifiée avec une augmentation de 30%
des opérations depuis samedi 30 janvier
exemple à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux ou des
contrôles ont été effectués
on n'est plus dans la pédagogie ça fait
longtemps qu'on est bien dans la dans la
verbalisation des cas qui posent
problème mais comme je le dis avec
pragmatisme éventuellement avec
souplesse avec discernement
c'est tout drôle de fonctionnaires de
police autre point de contrôle ce samedi
soir au rond point des droits de l'homme
à guyancourt
par ces temps qui sont quand même assez
compliqué c'est tout à fait normal de
contrôler web pour me demander de
présenter mon identité ainsi que mon
emploi c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est dès
que je pouvais continuer mon chemin avec
mon attestation
c'est bien passé 65000 contrôles ont été
faits sur le territoire seulement pour
la journée du 30 janvier et 6000
verbalisations ont eu lieu à la suite de
ces opérations de contrôle